remember MySpace the Facebook of the
2000s that dominated the social media
space despite early popularity today no
one even seems to remember their myspace
password so what went wrong
[Music]
welcome to Hari Saudis da star in August
of 2003 with several universities they
all had Friendster accounts and saw the
potential of social networking so the
group decided to mimic the most popular
features of Friendster and create the
own platform called MySpace and within
just 10 days they were able to develop
MySpace and get it ready for launch this
was mainly due to Brad Greenspan who was
a CEO of a universe he was very
supportive of the project and provided a
team with programmers and resources
Chris de wolf was appointed the very
first CEO and Tom Anderson was the first
president bear is very insistent that
had to be free in order to build a
really strong community
the first myspace users were a universe
employees the company would even hold
contests to see who could get the most
amount of people to sign up on to
MySpace myspace was quickly gaining
users and soon enough it was on par with
Friendster
ye universes resources were essential in
the fast rise of myspace and the
eventual take over a Friendster this was
because browse able to employ the help
of tech experts like tow Anwen and abre
would calm these men played an integral
role in the software architecture and
really set up myspace to succeed they
utilized a much superior ColdFusion
server hosting system despite Friendster
having ten times more developers myspace
was 10 times faster than Friendster this
was because ColdFusion much faster than
the Java server pages used by Friendster
and this is allowed myspace to easily
overtake Friendster and never look back
my spaceship growing in popularity very
quickly among teens and young adults and
in February of 2005 Chris and Mark
Zuckerberg would actually discuss buying
Facebook but Chris Tata
Mark's offer of 75 million was way too
much for the young platform and as a
result the deal will never go through
but lucky for the founders they would
never have to deal with the
repercussions of not going through with
that deal as
cash out of course they would hold on to
some equity but nothing major in July of
2005 a universal myspace was purchased
by Rupert Murdoch's News Corporation
these are the people behind Fox News the
deal would total 580 million dollars of
which 327 million dollars is said to be
from MySpace within just the first year
myspace would triple its original
purchase price and the other companies
that lost in a bidding war from myspace
got very frustrated in fact become
chairman Sumner Redstone would actually
fire CEO for failing in the acquisition
anyways in 2006 myspace were expanding
to the UK China and several other
countries as well and that same year in
August of 2006 the 100 millionth myspace
account would be created and then in
November of 2007 myspace was joined
Google led OpenSocial Alliance this
included comments like LinkedIn and hi-5
and promoted a common set of standards
for software developers to write
programs for social networks but
Facebook on the other hand would never
join this and always remain independent
by late 2007 myspace was the dominant
social media network and it consistently
beat out its main competitor Facebook at
its peak in 2007 myspace would be valued
at 12 billion dollars but things would
take a sudden turn from MySpace on April
19th of 2008 Facebook would surpass
myspace and since then myspace has
consistently lost membership and
Facebook has never looked back the first
problem was that there was really no
comparison between MySpace and Facebook
Facebook was clearly the superior
product and this was mainly because
myspace lacked innovation Facebook takes
just seconds to learn and as a product
it is very user friendly MySpace on the
other hand pretty much looks identical
to how it looked when it launched
there's only been a handful updates
since then there are also very slow
adapting to new technologies like Ajax
this allows users to send messages
without opening a new browser window it
also allows them to import email
addresses into friends lists
and it also allowed for instant
messaging and Facebook trampled myspace
in all three of these Facebook also
allowed third-party developers to
develop apps on their website while
MySpace was very insistent that they
would develop their own apps they way to
almost a full year after Facebook to
allow developers onto the website
Facebook's a very popular social games
was one of the main reasons for success
like Farmville even people who are
considered MySpace Stars leave the
platform for example Tila Tequila who is
a modern rapper really gained most of
her popularity through her audience in
MySpace in 2006 Time magazine even named
her the queen of myspace and today she
says that she has lost her passion in
myspace and that she doesn't even
remember her password she says that she
stopped logging to myspace because it
just wasn't simple anymore and this
seems to be a common theme as Facebook
was towering our myspace they decided to
change from being a social network to a
social entertainment destination they
essentially gave up on trying to compete
with Facebook and try to go on their own
venture they were trying to reposition
themselves in the market but the problem
was that this is not the reason that
people started using myspace in the
first place by making this change
they weren't providing their users what
they were expecting or wanted recently
twitter has actually made a pretty
similar change to this and i've really
focused on live video and news twitter
to start pushing to become like facebook
but there's one key difference between
what twitter did and what myspace did
Twitter's users were already using
Twitter for news before Twitter really
started to focus on it so Twitter
actually improved what users were using
Twitter for in the first place but
myspace was moving away from what users
were using it for basically imagine
snapchat was losing users and as a
result they suddenly choose to focus on
games this would not help drive traffic
or keep users it would actually push
them away because that's not why they
got that app myspace should have changed
their purpose but is that's not what
they got wrong instead they should have
focused on how they could make their
user experience better and why people
preferred Facebook over MySpace this
fundamental misstep really set them up
for failure in the future
it was really hard to make changes and
really focus on what was important
because it was so corporate since news
corp bought my space my space was just a
small drop in the news corp ocean it was
often said that the news corporation
cared more about profits than the actual
user experience and this would explain
the really slow innovation News Corp
generates over nine billion dollars in
revenue every single year and myspace
sits in a small division called Fox
media interactive this division as a
whole only generated 1 billion dollars
at its peak this division only produced
10% of the company's revenue now this is
a significant portion but not by any
means a deal breaker for a News Corp
this really diverted focus away from
myspace and hindered them from making it
a good user experience if you take a
look at Facebook today they have bought
several other companies like whatsapp
but at this point
Facebook's main and only source of
revenue was Facebook so they really
focus on the user experience irritated
customers and myspace simply did not as
aggressively attract or retain users as
Facebook did and this was heavily due to
myspace being neglected by the news
corporation maybe Facebook would have
never blown up and myspace would be
still really big if it was never sold to
News Corp but now we'll never know
without innovation purpose or control
myspace was destined to fail it was just
a matter of time myspace was losing
millions of active users every single
month throughout 2010 in 2011 and in
March of 2011 myspace is officially put
up for sale they were aiming to sell
myspace for 100 million dollars but none
of the bits even came close to that the
closest bid was from specific media for
35 million dollars they had acquired it
for 327 million dollars so this was only
10% of that but it may have not actually
been an overall loss for News Corp
myspace was vastly successful at the
beginning and they were actually able to
score a nine hundred million dollar deal
with to Google for advertising so they
may have very well came off even or even
profited money from MySpace
but it definitely was not the success
they were looking for as they were
looking to turn myspace into
a company that it was during its peak
and it ended up just wasting a lot of
time even if it was profitable it really
wasn't worth News Corp's time
considering how big they are
since then myspace has changed hands and
today mirror did corporation owns them
they have also faced several terrible
issues for example when they were trying
to migrate their servers they lost 12
years of content permanently even after
all of that myspace actually still
around and there are a couple of million
users who actually still cling on to it
but I think that we would all agree that
MySpace's effectively dead myspace was
founded the original social media Giants
and really searched to its peak in the
late 2000s but since then without a real
purpose or innovation and being observed
is such a huge company has really taken
away their appeal and today they sit in
the Hall of failed internet products
along with AOL Yahoo an Internet
Explorer but like all of those myspace
was great during its time and he was
simply time to move on but that's all I
have for you guys on myspace make sure
comment down below what company you
would like me to cover next also if you
guys like this video make sure up to
like and consider subscribe me if you
like see more videos just like this one
but until then I'm Hari I'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]